présenté il ya un an comme une
entreprise de grande importance pour le
développement économique du québec
nemaska lithium s'est placée à l'abri de
ses créanciers le 23 décembre
québec a injecté 130 millions de dollars
dans cette aventure dont 80 millions en
capital actions
un investissement qui ne vaut plus que
13 millions aujourd'hui avec nos michel
nadeau expert en finances et en
gouvernance chez nadeau bonsoir soir que
s'est il donc passé que se passe-t-il
avec nemaska lithium bas au début
nemaska les surnoms c'est que le produit
de lithium est un produit qui va être en
forte demande avec les ordinateurs les
batteries les voitures électriques
donc on a mis en place et l'exploitation
de gisements le deuxième ou troisième
plus gros gisements au monde de lithium
actionnement l'édition vient d'amérique
du sud
alors là on est mieux au québec la mini
e bougie qui va vraiment produire une
forte teneur de bons volumes
or donc tout allait bien l'an passé on
lors de l'assemblée annuelle de 2018 en
descendent 18 décembre 2018
les échanges se sont rencontrés le
président guy bourassa dit sa voix très
bien je suis fier d'où nous sommes
rendus 18 décembre et la deux le titre
dahlab alors 76 il y avait une baisse
parce que morgan stanley avait publié
des rapports un peu négatif sur la
surcapacité de la production de lithium
aidé mais toujours été là l usine à
shawinigan et laminoirs 300 km au nord
de chibougamau
tout était parfait 18 200 13 février 58
jours après on nous annonce le
communiqué qui manquent 375 millions et
la baisse évidemment c'est le début de
la descente aux enfers le site
aujourd'hui phocéenne et mais il ya
beaucoup de gens lors de l'assemblée
annuelle en décembre 2018 était
convaincu rassuré par le président que
tout allait bien et cetera là on se dit
on nous informe que le projet qui devait
coûter un milliard cent millions en
coûtera 1 milliard 500 millions qui
manquent 375 millions et là de tout au
long de 2010
on essayait de trouver du financement on
intéresser des gens qui ont regardé ça
mais évidemment les vautours veulent
avoir le truc pour pas cher you 400
millions qui ont été investis
hélas que ce que les investisseurs
doutent et facile j'ai donc mauvaise
planification mauvaise évaluation
oui c'est sa mauvaise évidemment le dès
la mise à valeur d'un gîte ministres ou
hauts risques
la teneur les coûts de construction et
ensuite au cours du marché le cours du
marché sont verra mais la demande a
visiom semble assez ferme
mais les la teneur du gie du giro au
québec est bonne c'est ce manque et
s'ils écoutent les coûts de construction
les coûts de construction
on ne sous des valuées d'environ 400
millions le coût de mise en place de la
mine et l'usiné shawinigan
donc on efface tout ça dites vous
l'entreprise se place sous la protection
des tribunaux le 23 décembre dernier
ça veut donc dire quoi par exemple pour
l'investissement du gouvernement du
québec
après c'est tout ce que probablement
sovac perdu 400 millions qui ont investi
l'argent du gouvernement du québec
les petits investisseurs le titre monte
à 2 dollars de dollars 50 pouces offre
sera probable devrait être a dit le
petit investisseur qui nous regardent ce
soir ben y en a beaucoup qui nous
écoutent pas nous regarder qui nous
écrivent en ce moment ray ils vont tout
perdre
il y a de fortes chances qu'ils perdent
tout il faut peut-être se ramasser le
type océane et demi actuellement la fin
à la clôture aujourd'hui je crois que le
6 février il va être aidé y ait de la
cour de la porte à la bourse de toronto
or là évidemment ça va être en ce jour
marcheurs quelles sont leurs recours
bah les recours ça sera très difficile
de prouver que j'ai vu des erreurs de
gestion la compagnie voarick les coûts
de construction
il a devant une partie de la demande de
la production future un groupe s'appelle
orion et là il y aurait eu des mauvais
calcul
on ne sait pas trop évidemment qu'est ce
qui a manqué la compagnie à ses vaille
dans son communiqué de février là 2019
qui est pourquoi on s'est retrouvé à 315
millions
de capitaux nécessaires pour compléter
l'opération est là si on n'a pas réussi
à trouver ça c'est parce que les
investisseurs ont vu qu'ils avaient
peut-être d'autres choses aussi
alors donc c'est pour ça que
actuellement là tout est arrêté envoyé
vers nisé et les installations puis on
verra
et donc que va faire jacques mallette
qui a été nommé hier président du
conseil d'administration qui avait
orchestré la restructuration de quebecor
world
entre 2007 et 2009 ce qui est beau
essayer c'est de trouver de nouveaux
investisseurs
évidemment ces nouveaux investisseurs la
réalité de du lithium est toujours là la
demande semble très prometteuse
le gîte est très riche le volume et les
quantités sont bonnes or le travail de
monsieur mali tu savais de vendre dit
regardez là il ya 400 millions qui ont
été investis sur un projet d'un milliard
et demi
vous avez l'occasion de ramasser soit
pour pas cher or là il ya peut-être il
ya toujours des gens qui veulent acheter
à prix d'aubaine qui vont peut-être dire
là avec une vision long terme mais des
poches très profondes à envoyer les on
va foncer mais évidemment ils feront pas
de cadeaux à ceux qui ont investi 4 100
bio le gouvernement du québec va-t-il
devoir injecter encore plus d'argent
dans les masses cas parce que je crois
comprendre que le gouvernement du québec
veut que nemaska réussisse oui le
gouvernement du québec veut nemaska
évidemment tout dépend de qui sera
l'investisseur orientait des grandins
des grandes firmes d'investissement
minière des grands groupes miniers qui
vont vous dire on préfère y aller tout
seul on veut pas d'intervention du
gouvernement
mais ce qui arrive souvent dans des cas
comme ça les chasseurs d'aubaines ce
sont de petites entreprises qui vont
essayer de fiancé de faire financer le
projet par investissement québec par le
gouvernement du québec par d'autres
levier économique québécois et vous
pensez qu'elle va survivre l'entreprise
nemaska lithium j'entends ce que la
demande pour le lithium justifie ces
deuxième ou troisième plus gros j'étais
au monde or donc il ya une capacité et
ça évidemment il en est à 1 milliard de
livres
arthur de la mienne là ça vaut la peine
mais évidemment ce qui est triste c'est
que le premier chapitre
or a été une triste histoire mais pour
l'avenir la demande judiciaire
elle est réelle le gîte il est réel or
donc dans ce contexte là pour celui
qu'ils soient patients et qui on va
l'argent ça vaudrait la peine
michel nadeau merci pour cette analyse
ce soir